hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend uh Conan here as if you didn't
know that hanging out here with Sona
mosesian and uh of course the that Scamp
Matt Gourley I'm sorry you're just
laughing because we did three two one
and then usually I go right into it but
this time I took I would say two or
three beats before I started speaking if
you would have counted it would have
gone three two one nine eight seven yeah
I took a little extra time to uh create
a tension in the room which then I could
exploit because I'm a master of this
medium there's no tension oh that's
right I forgot who I was dealing with
you're six gummies into the wind right
now
she puts them in her scrambled eggs in
the morning but you know what's really
funny is that we were laughing our asses
off just goofing around and Adam sacks
who's in the you know who's our our
master and our Guru he's in the room and
he was like enough he said all laughing
has to be done on Mike yeah no laughing
off my yeah no laughing
and so that's why I think I took a long
pause was to try and kill the joy that
was in the room before we got started I
see yeah we were having a good time we
were no no I know we were having a
wonderful time and and Adam sacks comes
by and you're what fruit feel free to
defend yourself Adam and don't have any
fun on Mike yeah but uh what happened
you sensed I'm not going to defend
myself because I agree with your with
the way you're characterizing what
happened you guys were laughing we don't
have a lot of time we've got 35 minutes
now wait a minute why don't we have a
lot of time there's another podcast
coming okay let me tell you something
this is my podcast building what do you
mean I'm being shoved out of my own
studio so we don't have a lot of time
and you guys were laughing and I was
looking at the clock and I got nervous
and I said laughing's okay but only do
it while the mics are but like what
would happen if you went out and told
the guys Conan O'Brien's in there
they're like oh my God oh my God and you
know what is they start quivering uh
it's going to be another five minutes is
that the end of the world no that would
probably be fine yeah oh probably be
fine I can't speak for them I think it
would be fun five minutes yeah this
building we're painting my face on the
side of it yeah you know and also you
explaining this is now prolonged this
intro because we still have to do bits
and Giggles
sure bits and Giggles sure
I didn't slave away for 40 years to
craft a career in bits and giggles
we're here changing the way man thinks
about man uh better late than never is
that what we're doing I know I just said
something and thought it would help I
don't know what we're doing no but I'll
tell you this uh I'm Adam I do
appreciate the hard work and yes we do
need someone to crack the whip
occasionally and let us know that our
tomfoolery our hijinks bits and Giggles
our bits and Giggles uh maybe are
wasting time and we've got to make way
for the next podcast what if this is
part of our process right oh
a hollow molar and out drops a gummy
edible
I wish I was as high as you guys say I
am but I'm not well you used to be I I
did and now with twins of course yes
[Music]
can I ask a question this is I know
personal but if you're breastfeeding you
can't right because I did it yeah yeah
because the gummy would it would come
out in the milk is that right it would
be like a full gummy it would come out
the nipple yeah did I just picture a
gummy shooting out the nipples into
Mikey or Charlie's mouth uncomfortable
that's what I picture I picture Mikey or
Charlie or one on each brass and all of
a sudden each one goes I got the prize
yeah
they sleep really well that day yeah so
it's totally worth it did you ever get
up in the middle of the night and find
the moshing
just in their cribs in their cribs just
rolling around and just moshing on top
of each other no I didn't yeah glad you
answered that honestly yes no I have not
seen them moshing the strangest thing
that's ever come out of your breasts
honestly milk what the
what is that that's gotta be a very
strange thing it's weird it's really and
I had to pump and so you put like like a
cow you put these things on your boobs
and then it just like squeezes liquid
out of your nipples like I have a
question okay
thank you Matt
if I attach those to my nipples yes and
they sucked really hard for a long time
would any milk come out is there any
milk in there oh boy there I just don't
know about how humans work I think there
have been some instances where men have
lactated right um first of all your dad
is a doctor yeah so if you asking this
question is already very um my dad said
he was a doctor but when we asked to see
uh any kind of certificate he got real
squirrely where was he going every day I
think to the train station eat a
sandwich he was going to the doctor yeah
yeah no it's weird it is weird the the
first of all I don't think milk would
come out of your uh nip oh here we go
what does it play uh male lactation has
been observed in a few domesticated
animals including cats goats and guinea
pigs on rare occasions and also it says
uh here's some transgender men and non
non-binary people nurse their babies and
use the term chest feeding or body
feeding okay there you go um why do you
guys want to lactate first of all let me
tell you this if science made it
possible if science made it possible
yeah for uh men to lactate I think women
would be very happy if they could get up
for some of those midnight feedings I
you're right or would you be jealous
would I be jealous that like tack would
be able to breastfeed instead of me yeah
uh no I wouldn't but I
um I don't I just it's not like it's not
like it's fun when you like squeeze your
boob and like milk shoots out I can't
think of anything it'd be more fun
at people I would too you know and I'd
be you know what I'd love to do is if if
I was at the beach and I didn't have my
shirt on just go like oh man and gorley
be like what is it oh this part of my
chest is real sore and then I just push
it and shoot you right knee it's a
sporting flower that's part of your body
I go to the carnival when you're
supposed to shoot those water guns into
the Clown's mouth and see if you can
raise the balloon up the wall yes yeah I
would do that too this is why men don't
lactate
if men could lactate yeah the baby would
get none of the milk right because we'd
be going to carnivals and trying to
shoot at ducks with our lactation milk
right and we'd be playing pranks on each
other yeah on my my chest is sore what
is it man squirt gotcha yeah exactly I
think it would be a huge disservice to
babies if men lactate it so I think it's
important that women just yeah do it you
know I think that uh you know we
followed Adam Sax's advice and we got
back on track and talked about some
really important stuff we got into some
tits and Giggles okay I'm sorry I just
you know what that's both I finally it's
also called note back yeah I'm checking
the boxes yeah you just made it finally
to the very top of my list of worst
people ever
mission accomplished yeah Hitler number
two who's Hitler oh he's number two on
the list now
Hitler number two well anyway our thanks
to uh Adam sacks for getting us uh to
settle down stop being silly so we could
get back to being silly